[Music]
we have a big elbow we perfectly know
how to make exports Marseille is a huge
place for the interconnection between
Africa Asia and the Middle East we need
to have president that is skill and
business skill in digital technology
because it's going to be the next huge
revolution and first of all isn't to
speak perfect English the current
president don't have any computer in his
desk so it's not a good sign I'm Kevin
Polizzi I'm the founder and the
president of Jaguar network iCloud
telecommunication and artificial
intelligence company based in masse we
want a single market for Europe because
companies that are growing in the US are
dressing one country with one language
and nearly one tax policy so that might
be the next great move to Europe in
order to be sure that it's not only a
political Europe but it's an economic
Europe
[Music]
[Music]
with more than 450 startup making a lot
of innovation and we have the first
regional French tech territory
[Music]
by Milan Linate I'm 50 years old
I'm the Thunderer and the managing
director of startup which called spoth
we are developing a shoe stand out with
that box we can scan the quality of the
fuel onboard the car in less than 30
seconds and from having the information
the fingerprint of the fuel then we can
cut co2 and pollutant emissions clearly
yes we need to have an open mind
president someone which will be able to
see where the world is coming is going
cloudy and and again the digital world
is a something which coming to Faust now
and clearly we really need to have
someone will be at full and would be
able to think about how we can use that
to leverage France people and then also
to allow to create jobs in the new this
new technology world I don't have a wish
candidate we're going to see what
happened it's like a football coach at
the end it's a team and if you want to
develop the business you need to be the
manager of the team unleash the power of
your employee and open them to grow and
that's not so hard at the end it's just
a question of passion and a question of
human skill